relaxing sleep station I started opening
up very publicly using my story as a
differentiator I'm still concerned that
i'll need to get a job in a feature and
keep my business as my side hustle and
turn until it earns enough how do i be
true to my story while not completely
turning off potential employers who will
find all this information with me with a
simple google search yeah I think that's
great i think actually and i'll talk
about you know the authenticity i'd say
a lot of great startup it's kind of
spawned out of people like yourself who
work in doing a full time job to someone
else and then in the evenings and
weekends creating their ideas and then
ultimately build a business and it's
great if you can get a big corporation
to pay for you to be moonlight in and
creating the next your amazon business
that you're going to create in in your
bedroom or in the figure into whatever
you're doing it then that's a fantastic
thing to do so i don't think there
should be any guilt associated with that
i think that's the way you know people
operate in 2016 i think the other thing
honestly if people came to us in our
company and said actually I want to
start a business oh I'd applaud you and
they can be full-time employees and
colleagues with me and paige and i think
you will be surprised there's a lot of
entrepreneurs out there even leaders of
big companies out there it would really
encourage their colleagues and their
employees to start arm their idea and
incubate their ideas and then you know
get ready to fly so I'm you know I think
it's worth pursuing and I when I just
look at look at the the range of
businesses they give you an example he
obviously I've mentioned this guy before
his genius and that's Marc Benioff for
Salesforce many us work with me back at
Oracle and Larry Ellison the chief
executive and chairman at the son of
Oracle knew mark was done this business
and was really happy for him to be
incubating it business while he's
moonlight
I work in full time an Oracle and now ma
I don't know the valuation of that
company cell source must be sixty
billion dollars one of the greatest
companies on the planet or sheer true
spectrum and it does amazing things
around communities through the sales of
foundation giving back to communities to
making a difference and building I'm
really leading the sort of Cranbury
revolution so that that's a really
example and that happened what 16 17
years ago tight I think we shouldn't
constrain ourselves to just say you know
I work for company I leave them and do a
start I think you know they're there can
be almost a perfect melting pot where
you can be working and working on your
idea at the same time and sign their
business and maybe even getting buddy to
start business for you and then as a
right tiny kind of flip over I think
this route I'm doing really well to this
theme of having a confidence to be your
true self because if you are worried
about a customer not buying for you
because of your story or company not
hiring you because your story that's
fine i'm not going to be a great fit for
you anyway there's going to be some if
you're looking for a part-time job to
support your business on the side there
will be some companies who will look at
what you're doing and won't want to hire
somebody who has their own part-time
thing they want to hire somebody who you
only get a kid to their company and
silly other people who will look at that
as an advantage like oh you're you're an
entrepreneur that's great like you can
help us because you understand
entrepreneurs and you could give us
advice and do a great job in your role
and so by putting that content out there
and by being yourself you will attract
the companies that are better fit for
you and the companies that aren't a
great fit they won't be interested in
you which is the same thing with your
customers if you're sharing your story
there are some people who won't connect
to it and that's fine those guys would
not be great customers for you and
there's going to be other two will like
madly deeply resonate with it and and
drive that extra 100 miles just to get
to you because they love what you're
about so you know you've already heard
it I mean I hire people even if they
have their own thing on the side I have
18 people on my team it's not any
we're close to what stage is that but
you just heard it from the CEO there to
you know thousands and thousands of
employees and they value people housing
from the side as well so I would
encourage you to go in and embrace what
you're doing maybe you've included on
your resume its supposed to try it out
yeah I see are the generality of the
Kearney area the other thing of them the
only area where it could get a bit testy
is if yeah I think this is speak to
authenticity integrity and your values
obviously it wouldn't be appropriate to
work for a company and then sort of
steal their ideas to become a competitor
that company sure you know but i think
you know parlor confidence confidence
comes through having really powerful
values and part of attics integrity and
also kind of connect yourself to to the
customer but i think is as long as it's
going to not a conflict and you're not
you're not going to kind of rip off the
company's intellectual property or stuff
like that then you know I think there's
a lot of companies out there where
exactly 12 is point you can find a
perfect marriage with you and a company
and their kind of ambition for their
colleagues to be really happy fulfilled
but also you know I also get just so
this is kind of a throwaway I do believe
companies of the future should believe
that they have a relationship for life
with the colleagues who work for them
and that might mean you know I traded it
to people here they might need sage they
might go starter in business 10 years x
seven years done they're always welcome
to come back to see so it's not it's not
like the old days be an elaborate kind
of career in one company is definitely
the case and I think it's great for the
economies for individuals who are
fantastic entrepreneurs to really be
able to express their business freedom
and really grow a lot of job creation
and wealth creation by going to start
your business and then at the right time
you can come back in you know we need
people who have got real experience of
living the life an entrepreneur going
for stop worrying about making table for
months the less sort of stuff from that
cash because the more we have people who
have
just walked in the shoes of our
customers then the more authentic was
going to be as a company so I think I
generally think I'd really encourage you
connect yourself to a company Evan set
with the values that you respect and
actually I think it could be a great
match